with our very favorite Court Jester  conservative that would be of course Liz  Cheney who is now threatening if Donald  Trump is a nominee in 2024 to run for  president herself I'm focused on what  we've got to do to save the country from  this very dangerous moment we're in  um you know not right now on on whether  I'm going to be a candidate or not  there's some if you were a third party  candidate it would be enough to stop  Trump  well we will do whatever it takes as I  said he will not be the president United  States again we will do whatever it  takes he will not be the president of  the United States now it sounds like  Bluster it is a little bit ominous  actually coming from Liz Cheney because  even though Liz Cheney pretends to be a  republican on all the crucial issues she  sides with the Democrats and she goes on  the Democrat TV stations and spouts  Democrat talking points and she is a a  representative of the Democrat  establishment which does have a lot of  power